it is still a mystery why do we age and
what controls aging scientists think
cellular senescence is the mechanism
it's a cellular state where cell
undergoes permanent growth arrest and
loses the ability to grow and divide
compared to a normal cell senescence
cells are abnormally enlarged and flat
they have increased nuclear cytoplasm to
nuclear ratio they lack DNA replication
capability they have increased cycling
dependent kinase Inhibitors and nuclear
Associates Associated heterochromatin
Focus but what triggers the senescence
it turns out prolonged DDR response
telomere shortening and oncogene
activation can be a trigger for cellular
citizens
so how senescence can be reversed that
is an important thing and scientists are
figuring out cenolytics and inkt
immunotherapy to reverse senescence
watch the full video to know more